one day before his term expires
philippines president rodrigo duterte's
government has ordered the closure of
investigative website rappler the
independent news site run by nobel prize
winning journalist maria reza has long
been targeted by the duterte government
for its reporting on the philippines
drugs war on tuesday the securities and
exchange commission reaffirmed its order
from 2018 for the site to seize
operations resa has said rappler isn't
shutting down and that it will pursue
all legal options to have the order
quashed
our goal
is to continue
holding the line you've heard me say
that forever we're not going to
voluntarily give up our rights and we
really shouldn't i've continued to
appeal for that because when you give up
your rights you're never going to get
them back
dwl's asia pacific bureau chief georg
matas visited the reptile offices in
manila and spoke to journalist paterno
ismaquel ii about what the shutdown
order means for media freedom in the
philippines
paterno thanks for joining me
how much of a blow is this for your
organization and is this the end of
repler
of course it's not the end of rappler
we have prepared for this kind of
scenario of course
we are on high alert right now but we
are very much prepared for this and
we have
we have
conditioned our staff
through the years for a scenario like
this so
it's it is business as usual for rappler
and in fact we are preparing for our
coverage of the inauguration of
president marcos tomorrow so is this
this is the last day of the duterte
government is this a parting shot from
duterte well it's not for me to say but
i think your viewers would be
intelligent enough to note that yeah
today is i mean yesterday when the
decision was issued it was two days
before the end of the duterte
administration so you know um people can
deduce um on their own and uh it's not
for me to say but i would again repeat
it is business as usual for us we will
continue doing our jobs so you don't
think it's exactly connected that this
is the last chance of duterte to issue
something like this well it is not for
me to say but we can probably connect
the dots on our own and i would say that
in this country and well anywhere in the
world nothing really happens without a
political connection
so you can intelligently deduce that
well
it might have something to do with it
and well
all we have to do is to roll with the
punches
what does this decision mean for free
media in the philippines
well uh obviously this is an
attack
against
breast freedom
because rappler has been
just doing its job as as a journalist as
the fourth estate and um well if people
other media other journalists would see
how rapper is being treated
it might
you know scare them or
you know they might shy away from doing
critical stories and i think that is the
the biggest impact of this on the the
industry it creates a chilling effect
rappler is um unaffected by this uh
chilling effect we continue to do our
jobs
as best as we can but you know other
media outlets might not be
might be more vulnerable than us because
of the corporate structure of
the the other media outlets owned by big
businessmen controlled by big
businessmen rappler is
lucky to have this
environment that fosters
free
independent reporting but you know the
effect on the others
it really creates a chilling effect and
that is
what worries us and worries many
watchdogs around the world
so you can still work
of course it's not a question of we can
can we still work i mean it's never a
question uh
our newsroom is uh bustling today our
eyes are set on the goal which is to
report
dark days for press freedom thanks very
much thank you very much
you